de gigantesques battues avaient été
organisées pour retrouver laetitia
delhez 14 ans et sabine dardenne âge et
du même âge disparu à des endroits
différents le 28 il 9 août dernier hier
soir les voisins des familles des jeunes
filles respire et enfin à chercher
vraiment dans tous les coins dans tous
les domaines tout le monde a été
solidaire est halal on était un peu
perdu parce qu'on ne savait dans quel
coin chez reiter même site un témoignage
concernant le métier suspects ramené les
enquêteurs jusque dans cette maison
était de charge
deux hommes et une femme y ont été
arrêtés l'un des hommes avaient déjà été
condamnés au fond de crise grecque est
rassurant pour les procureurs chargés de
l'index sabine et laetitia aurait été
abusée sexuellement
et il n'exclut pas avoir à faire avec
quatre jeunes filles disparues de
l'année dernière en belgique reste
on va
maintenant il faudrait
comprendre au moins tenter de comprendre
valérie ermite revient sur les deux
semaines de cauchemar qui ont bouleversé
la belgique le point sur l'enquêté
marc dutroux n'avait malheureusement pas
menti sur ses propres indications les
enquêteurs belges ont exhumé les corps
de ham et 2f yeux disparu un an plus tôt
en belgique marc dutroux n'a pour
l'instant jamais menti le 15 août
dernier alors que les policiers
enquêtent sur la disparition de la jeune
laetitia il avoue et livre la surprise
générale de jeune fille laëtitia et
sabine mans dès lors marc dutroux est
soupçonné d'être l'auteur de plusieurs
autres disparitions
le 17 août il avoue encore il a bien
enlevé un essieu mais aussi julie et
mélissa
les deux fillettes seront retrouvées
mortes à sarlat buissière leurs obsèques
seront celles de toute la belgique
une belgique effondré sur le symbole sur
les affiches de tous les enfants qu'il
faut mettre en garde
découvrant l'horreur la belgique ça vire
alors entre la peine et la colère la
polémique s'installe mais les propres
parents de la petite mélissa ne demande
pas la peine de mort pour du trou bien
au contraire autres prêteurs protection
de monsieur du tout
parce que on a bien peur qu'il se fasse
éliminer et ça ne nous intéresse pas son
appel semble avoir été entendu dans sa
prison marc dutroux est effectivement
surveiller contrôler toutes les 7
minutes 30
hier un autre père a lancé un appel
c'est celui de marc dutroux lui-même
pour son fils possible ce qu'ils peuvent
attendre qu'ils peuvent pour ne pas être
dénoncée en faire en sorte que ce serait
si toi des arbres en clair ils lui
demandent de dénoncer son réseau son
réseau
quel est il avec marc dutroux une
dizaine de personnes ont déjà été
arrêtées dont l'inspecteur de police
zico soupçonné d'avoir couvert du trou
dans un trafic de voitures volées
aujourd'hui la presse belge parle de
magistrats et de gendarmes dont les noms
circuleraient dans le dossier l' affaire
dutroux est loin d'être terminée
13 août 1996 que marc dutroux avait été
arrêté cette affaire devait provoquer
souvenez vous un véritable séisme en
belgique au fur et à mesure que l'on
allait découvrir les monstruosités des
crimes qu'ils avaient commis notamment
en compagnie de sa femme match et c'est
ici qu'il faut creuser l'an cynique un
marc dutroux arrêté quelques jours plus
tôt le pédophile est venu en personne
avec les gendarmes indiqué l'endroit où
fouiller la belgique découvre alors les
visages de julie et mélissa deux
fillettes disparues depuis de longs mois
le début du cauchemar accusant tour à
tour ses complices du trou joue avec les
enquêteurs
un mois plus tard en septembre 96 il
avoue deux autres moeurs
un essieu sont retrouvés enterrés sous
ce hangar pour les parents la souffrance
puis très vite la colère car le
pédophile était bien connu de la justice
il avait déjà été condamné en 89 pour
séquestration et viol tout un peuple
se pose alors la même question pourquoi
les enquêteurs n'ont ils pas suspecter
plutôt cet homme tout un pays et mais
une même hypothèse du trou et protégés
non ce n'est pas parfait que de crier à
6 le blasphème résidait plutôt dans
l'hypocrisie yeux ou dans de pieuses
déclaration qui voudraient étouffer les
pourquoi que notre coeur est votée nous
tous a posé pour ne pas étouffer la
vérité c'est la marche blanche 350 mille
personnes viennent à bruxelles
soutenir des parents devenus les porte
parole d'une belgique en souffrance pour
lever les soupçons
une commission denquête se met au
travail audition après audition les
parlementaires découvre l'incompétence
des gendarmes
le dysfonctionnement de la justice la
guerre des polices
mais dans un rapport rendu public en
février dernier il conclu non du trou
n'était pas protégée il ya quinze jours
le pédophile avait été pour la première
fois confronté aux parents at il commis
d'autres enlèvement at il tout avoué
depuis dutroux ne dit plus rien
l'instruction n'est toujours pas close
son procès est attendu en 99
c'est le procès que toute la belgique
attend celui de marc dutroux le
pédophile belge est incarcéré depuis
août 96
la population veut maintenant connaître
la vérité sur les circonstances de
l'enlèvement de six fillettes et la mort
de quatre d'entre elles
une affaire qui avait provoqué une vive
douleur dans le pays et même au delà
le rappel des faits avec pascal justice
et marque faith sabine et laetitia sorte
de l'enfer d'une geôle aménagé par marc
dutroux dans le sous-sol de son domicile
où elles ont été séquestrées et violé
laetitia ya passé six jours
sabine presque trois mois en ce mois
d'août 96 des belges découvrent une
bande de malfaiteurs kidnappeurs
d'enfants marc dutroux ferrailleurs et
chômeurs son épouse michelle martin
institutrice
michel lelièvre le complice toxicomanes
et michel nihoul soupçonné d'être le
commanditaire des enlèvements
tous seront sur le banc des assises au
procès d'arlon non seulement pour
association de malfaiteurs enlèvement
séquestration et viol d'enfants mais
aussi pour assassinat car dans les
jardins des propriétés de marc dutroux
on a retrouvé quatre corps ceux de julie
melissa and he is lieu la belgique
chancel de douleur puis vient
l'indignation
je suis plus révoltés contre la justice
que quand marc dutroux l'ajuster salviac
c'était fini le fait les comme l'appelle
le père de mélissa a déjà été condamné
pour séquestration et viol de mineure
dès le lendemain de la disparition de
julie et mélissa il est suspecté
surveillé par la gendarmerie pendant
cinq mois
son domicile et même perquisitionné en
vain alors que les fillettes sont
enfermées dans la cave
alors on s'interroge qui est responsable
d'un tel ratage du trou et est il
protégé travail est il pour un réseau en
octobre 96 l'indignation des belges
tourne à la colère le juge d'instruction
jean marc conrad a participé à un dîner
de soutien aux familles des victimes et
la cour de cassation y voit un signe de
partialité
la population elle ne comprend pas qu'on
écarte de l'anc est celui qu'elle
considère comme un héros depuis la
libération de sabine et laetitia pendant
une semaine
la belgique connaît grève générale et
manifestations
il faudra l'intervention des familles de
victimes pour que la marche blanche se
déroulent dans le calme
trois cent cinquante mille personnes
dans la rue en mémoire des petites
victimes
jamais la belgique ne s'étaient
mobilisés de la santé
le 23 avril 98 et là stupeur marc
dutroux s'évade sa cavale n'a duré que
quelques heures mais a laissé un
souvenir amer aux belges des belges qui
attendent depuis sept ans et demi de
connaître la vérité sur les
circonstances de l'enlèvement de six
fillettes et de la mort de quatre
d'entre elles
c'est le procès que
attend il débutera lundi celui de marc
dutroux le pédophile belge est incarcéré
depuis août 96
la population veut maintenant connaître
la vérité sur les circonstances de
l'enlèvement de six fillettes et la mort
de quatre d'entre elles chaque soir
jusqu'à lundi nous y reviendrons voici
d'abord le rappel de cette affaire qui
avait provoqué une vive douleur dans le
pays et bien au delà
pascal justice et marc felix en plein
mois d'août de l'année 96
les belges découvrent une bande de
malfaiteurs en quelques heures
marc dufour de serre ailleurs michelle
martin son épouse et michel lelièvre le
confie ce toxicomane vont plonger le
pays dans l'effroyable univers d'un
kidnappeur d'enfants dans les sous sols
de ces deux missiles qui l'a lui même
aménagé marc dutroux a séquestré au
moins six fillettes
toutes ont été violées et pour quatre
d'entre elles la mort était au bout du
calvaire seul sabine et laetitia en sont
sorties vivantes
c'était le 15 août 96 le début de l'
affaire dutroux
quelques jours plus tard
en creusant les jardins des différents
domiciles de dutroux on découvre les
dépouilles de julie melissa anne et
essieux la belgique chancel de douleur
vient ensuite l'indignation
je suis plus révoltés contre la justice
du cot marc dutroux la justice savent
bien que c'est un film le fait les comme
l'appelle le père de mélissa a déjà été
condamné pour séquestration et viol de
mineure suspect numéro 1 dès le
lendemain de la disparition de julie et
mélissa marc dutroux est surveillé par
la gendarmerie pendant cinq mois son
domicile et même perquisitionné en vain
alors que les fillettes sont enfermées
dans la cave
alors on s'interroge qui est responsable
d'un tel ratage du trou et est il
protégé travail est il pour un réseau
arrêté deux jours après marc dutroux
michel nihoul est soupçonné d'être le
commanditaire de l'enlèvement de
laetitia homme d'affaires condamné à
plusieurs reprises pour banqueroute
frauduleuse
michel nihoul se vante d'avoir organisé
des parties signent pour la haute
société belge mais nie toute implication
dans un réseau pédophile en octobre 96
l'indignation des belges tourne à la
colère à cause cette fois d'une décision
de justice le juge d'instruction jean
marc conrad a participé à un dîner de
soutien aux familles des victimes et la
cour de cassation y voit un signe de
partialité
la population elle ne comprend pas qu'on
écarte de l'anc est celui qu'elle
considère comme un héros
depuis la libération de sabine et
laetitia
pendant une semaine la belgique connaît
un climat pré insurrectionnel de grève
générale et de manifestations axe
symbolique les pompiers arrosent le
tribunal pour laver la justice il faudra
l'intervention des familles de victimes
pour que la marche blanche se déroule
dans le calme marquant le silence dans
le temps et dans la dignité parce que
nous la faisons des milices a350 1000
personnes dans la rue en mémoire des
petites victimes
jamais la belgique ne s'étaient
mobilisés de la sorte pour calmer les
esprits une commission parlementaire est
chargé de mettre au jour les
dysfonctionnements de l'enquète
incompétence mauvaise transmission des
informations guerre des polices
le rapport rendu six mois plus tard et
sans concession le constat est tragique
si les bonnes décisions avaient été
prises en 95
les enfants auraient sans doute été
retrouvé peut-être même vivante
la chronique du déroulement de cette
enquête est la chronique d'un échec
annoncé
pendant qu'on analyse les erreurs du
passé l'enquète continue sous la
direction d'un nouveau juge
d'instruction jacques langlois qui ne
cache pas son point de vue marc dutroux
est un pervers isolé et michel nihoul
n'a pas sa place au procès mais la
justice belge ne le suis pas michel
nihoul sera bien jugé arlon aux côtés de
michel lelièvre michelle martin et marc
dutroux
un procès sous haute surveillance pour
éviter que marc dutroux ne s'échappe
comme il le fit le 23 avril 98 pendant
quelques heures ce jour-là les belges
effaré ont fait hésiter entre le rire et
les pleurs
voilà
les insultes colle à la peau de marc but
à 46 ans il a le triste privilège d'être
l'homme de la belgique ainsi noël
violeur et tueur est furieux avait 17 et
19 ans julie et mélissa 8 ans des
adolescentes les enfants victimes du
trou et très vite étiqueté pédophiles
mais selon les experts psychiatres ce
n'est pas son profil
c'est un cas psychiatrique mais quand
même un cas hors norme
parce que vraiment qu'à neuf par la
virulence la violence cento mais c'est
je pense très clairement un pervers
sadique ce pas du tout un pédophile mais
en gros c'est quelqu'un qui est requise
la haine donc qui place sa recherche de
licence dans un rapport à l'autre
d'emprise de vie dénonce de fascination
selon les psychiatres qui l'ont examiné
marc dufour rejette sa jeunesse il
grandit à auvers de charleroi fils d'un
couple d'instituteurs aîné de cinq
enfants
l'homme noir si avec beaucoup de
violence le personnage de sa mère à 16
ans il plie bagage
quelqu'un qui a dû se battre très jeune
seul et je répète c'était pas pour ça
que j'ai exclu ses actes mais ça
explique certains comportements certains
mécanismes de défense peut-être
aujourd'hui divorcée sa mère est
toujours installé dans le village
elle et son fils se détestent depuis
longtemps bien avant l'âge d'un but de
l'ex madame lounge vous êtes en contact
encore avec votre fils ou ou pas non pas
depuis combien les âmes
pourquoi madame ans
lorsque mis en avant par le même pu tuer
mais à mon sens des retours et ses films
et plus de contacts vous ne voulez plus
rentrer en contact avec votre fils vous
aime rire vient de madame d'avoir un
fixe comme ça laisse un fils condamné
une première fois en 80 6 à 13 ans de
prison pour des enlèvements des
séquestration et du viol de cinq jeunes
filles dont des mineures malgré l'avis
défavorable du procureur général marc
dutroux ne purge que la moitié de sa
peine libre le faire ailleurs vie
d'allocation de trafiquants tout vendre
en prison il s'est marié avec michelle
martin déjà complices de ces premiers
crimes
père de deux enfants il en aura trois
autres avec elle pas de suivi
thérapeutique du trouve récidive enlève
violent et cette fois élimine ses
victimes
les à aucun moment il ne semble éprouver
de remords lui il a trouvé sa solution
drilles être eu la réponse à sa question
distancié il connaît son mode dégelis
ans il s'y adonne envers et contre tout
pour ce qu'il arrêterait devant les
experts marc dutroux insiste sur son
courage sa philanthropie à l'égard des
plus faibles le criminel n'est pas fou
il est responsable de ses actes
quand danemark
la réclusion à perpétuité un verdict
sans surprise ou un mac l'expérience
sensible la prison à vie avait assorti
d'un commentaire et diderot m'a souri
aux spurs je crois que vous vous en
sortez quand même mieux que le plus peur
de vos victimes qui seront plus forte du
monde des vivants
ma fille âme qui est morte oui à mémoire
elle a été là tous les jours et je crois
qu'elle peut être qu'elle veut un truc
très fier
des nerfs qui lâchent après avoir
attendu ce verdict si longtemps michelle
martin l'ex-femme de marc dutroux et
condamné à 30 ans de prison
aucune circonstance atténuante michel
lelièvre l'homme de main toxicomanes
écopent de 25 ans clémence de la cour en
revanche pour michel nihoul cinq ans de
prison pour trafic de drogue
laetitia de l'est étaient convaincus de
l'implication de nuit ou dans son
enlèvement
c'est une déception je ne suis pas quant
à fait contents de ce qu'ils savaient
qu'un concours nul et ma foi - on
accepte quand même c'est que le jury ce
verdict du procès du siècle des anonymes
l'aurait voulu plus sévère je m'excuse
appel de la démo qui tranche avec la
dignité de sabine dardenne l'une des
deux survivantes ou la résignation de
parents pourquoi insatisfait par des
réponses judiciaires et demain il y aura
il y aura neuf ans que les petites ont
été enlevés et 1 heure actuelle mais
c'est toujours la même chose ça m'a
simplement pour c'est toujours partie
une jambe ou pour clore ce procès fleuve
le président a tenu à remercier tous les
acteurs et surtout les jurés la belgique
peut être fier de vous at il dit une
belgique qui veut désormais tourner la
page de la sphère du trou sans renier
pour autant un devoir de mémoire pour
les victimes